♪♪♪
♪ OOH YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH
THIS TIME OF YEAR I GET
THANKFUL BABE THANKFUL
FOR YOU ♪
♪ BUT NOW YOU'RE GONE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
YOU WERE SO INTELLIGENT
YOU WERE SO STRONG ♪
♪ WAITED MY WHOLE LIFE FOR
YOU SO DAMN LONG AND NOW I'M
SEEING YOU MOVING ON AND I'M
BEGGING YOU COME BACK HOME ♪
♪ EVERY NIGHT I TURN
THE TV ON AND CRY
I CRY I CRY
I TELL YOU WHY ♪
♪ I FEEL LIKE WE ARE ALL
GOING TO DIE
NO NO NO NO NO NO
SOME COME BACK FOR US ♪
♪ SO WE KNOW WE ARE
NOT ALONE.
WE WANT YOU BACK SOMEHOW.
♪ I NEED YOU IN MY LIFE
SO COME BACK FOR US
SO COME BACK BARACK.
WE DIDN'T KNOW JUST
WHAT WE HAD ♪
>> WE LIT 200 CANDLES FOR YOU.
♪ NOW THINGS ARE LOOKING BAD
LIKE REALLY BAD LIKE WORLD
WAR BAD, LIKE NUCLEAR BAD.
COUPLE BACK, BARACK.
♪ I SEE YOU HANG GLIDING
LIVING YOUR LIFE DROPPING
YOUR DAUGHTER OFF AT COLLEGE
WITH YOUR WIFE ♪
♪ AND YOU LOOK SO DAMN HAPPY
AND YOU DESERVE IT YEAH
BUT I'M A SELFISH MAN
AND I KNOW THERE IS OTHER ♪
♪ DEMOCRATS MORE THAN JUST
A FEW BUT WHEN I THINK
OF CHANGE THE CHANGE I WANT
IS YOU ♪
♪ I'M IN HELL DREAMING ABOUT
YOU AND MICHELLE
DREAMING BABY.
COME BACK BARACK.
COME IN OUT OF THE RAIN.
DON'T LEAVE US HERE ALONE ♪
IT'S DEFINITELY TOO COLD TO BE
RAINED ON.
♪ PLEASE PICK UP THE PHONE
THE WHITE HOUSE AIN'T A HOME
JUST COME BACK FOR US ♪
TRUCK AIN'T EVEN GOT A DOG, MAN.
>> IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME BARACK,
ALMOST AS LONG AS SINCE GUY
TALKED OVER A RECORD LIKE THIS.
FOR REAL, WHY WOULD YOU LEAVE
US?
OH, CAUSE YOU HAD TO BECAUSE OF
THE CONSTITUTION, BUT YOU CAN
COME BACK.
RIGHT?
OH, YOU CAN'T?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD UNDERMINE THE
VERY INSTITUTIONS THAT WE'RE
BARELY HOLDING ON TO AS IT IS?
I SEE.
I GUESS WE STUCK WITH THIS DUDE
FOR A WHILE THEN.
MAYBE YOU CAN COME BACK AND MAKE
A SPEECH?
HOW MUCH WOULD THAT COST?
FOR REAL?
OH, NO, WE DEFINITELY CAN'T
AFFORD THAT.
OIM JUST-- I'M JUST GETTING RAI
ON FOR NOTHING.
WELL, YOU ENJOY YOUR RETIREMENT,
HOMEY
♪ COME BACK FOR US
WE NEED YOU ALL SO BAD
SUPER BAD 2020'S LOOKING SAD
MAYBE MICHELLE COULD RUN ♪
♪ LIKE REALLY BAD
LIKE SUPER BAD
LIKE WHAT THEY HELL WE
GOING TO DO BAD ♪
>> NO.
LET'S NOT PUT MICHELE THROUGH
THAT, BUT IF SHE WANTED TO.
♪ COME BACK BARACK.
I'D VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN ♪
>> WHAT ABOUT GEORGE CLOONEY?
THAT DUDE WAS BATMAN.
THAT WOULD BE COOL.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I DON'T THINK THE
THREE OF US HAVE THE FIRMEST
GRASP ON GOVERNMENT.
BUT, HEY, HAPPY THANKSGIVING,
EVERYBODY.
♪♪♪
COME BACK BARACK ♪♪♪
.